I am going to make the case to you today
right now
actually why not what better time than
now that BuzzFeed was correct to publish
the 35 page dossier with all sorts of
allegations about Donald Trump and
Russia and all sorts of other stuff now
there's two points of view on this and
we'll go through both of them and then
I'll tell you where I come out and why
one is
BuzzFeed was right to publish it that's
what I believe the other one is BuzzFeed
was wrong to publish it and there's a
number of different reasons why people
are citing let's start with the argument
that BuzzFeed was wrong to publish the
35 page dossier the argument would be
well listen even though agencies knew
about the dossier for months it wasn't
published because the content could not
be verified right that's a primary
critique they published unverified
information is Trump into urine or is he
not into urine was he in touch with
Russian agent agents during the campaign
or wasn't he has Russia been grooming
trunk Trump for five years or have they
not been BuzzFeed published unverified
information for clicks and it is
something that no serious journalistic
entity would do especially when you're
talking about unverified intelligence
community sources we should be most
skeptical of sources from the
intelligence community especially when
they are unverified or not authorized to
speak or anonymous period and that this
is a really really bad thing to do
you're pushing rumor you're pushing
innuendo and this was the position for
example of Margaret Sullivan in an op-ed
that she wrote for the Washington Post
okay
she wrote about that she says a line was
crossed here by BuzzFeed in their
decision to publish these 35 pages
what's the other perspective well
obviously that BuzzFeed was right to
publish it but why lots of media outlets
have criticized BuzzFeed for doing it
but the Columbia Journalism Review has
pointed out quite as
doot Lee I might add that many of the
critiques from other media outlets
against BuzzFeed are quote
self-righteous and self-serving and that
BuzzFeed took all the right precautions
when they published these 35 pages first
of all number one and very importantly
wasn't a secret that the dossier was
being discussed at the highest levels of
government that's not a something that
tells us whether the content of it has
been verified we know that it hasn't but
there is no question and Donald Trump
admitted during his press conference
yesterday that yes the allegation of the
existence of this blackmail file was
discussed with him we know that
President Obama was briefed about it and
now we also have the Director of
National Intelligence on the record
about the briefing that took place both
the outgoing president and the incoming
president were briefed about this
whether or not the content of the
documents is accurate we are talking
undeniably about a document that is
being discussed in the Oval Office
proverbially speaking we don't know
exactly where President Obama was when
he was briefed about it
BuzzFeed made clear that while this is a
document that is the subject of these
high-level briefings that the
reliability of the content has not been
determined that they've been sitting on
this for month once they knew that this
was being discussed with the president
and the president of elect
president-elect they said hey here's
what's being discussed let's publish it
and let's see what else comes of the
publication but I want to go even
further than this Pat Richard toefl
who's the president of Pro Publica
tweeted the following about this release
and I think it's very relevant quote
also publication will likely accelerate
discovery of what in the dossier is true
and what is not that is what we should
all want this is spot on don't we want
the truth Pat on this given that Donald
Trump is barely more than a week away
from becoming president of the United
States yes I would say we would I mean
there's this old-school
respective of journalism that unless you
can a hundred percent verify a source
you don't publish Schmidt you won't
publish it but now with new media
there's an incentive to get clicks I
think and BuzzFeed released this
information but they did so with
important caveats and mentioned that a
lot of what they were publishing they
couldn't verify but to be perfectly
clear and Anderson Cooper and Kellyanne
Conway seemed to not be able to
understand each other on this this point
and I'll get to this later in the show
BuzzFeed was correct in publishing that
this 35 page document was something that
Trump had been briefed on they were
right about that and they said the
contents of it have not been verified
and here's where the critics really fall
apart for me I keep reading everything
in the dossier should have been verified
before its publication as Pat sort of
sort of gave us as a thought experiment
wait wait wait wait wait
were the allegations against Hillary
Clinton about Benghazi
all of which were proven false verified
before that story went viral and
documents were repeated Andrea sent out
and published by media outlets were the
allegations against Hillary Clinton and
her allies in the so called the email
scandal verified before they were
released no some redacted personal
information was taken care of and then
it was all put out no one cared that it
wasn't verified information in fact
everybody loved it and there's an
October story in the hill which details
the allegations about Donna Brazile
passed along debate questions to the
Clinton campaign and in the fourth
paragraph it says quote the emails which
have been made public in batches by
WikiLeaks have been largely unconfirmed
and are believed to have been stolen by
Russian intelligence no criticisms of
the mechanism there and only a focus on
the content I believe that given the
circumstances BuzzFeed was right to
release the documents with the caveats
that they included in their release that
the information itself has not been
verified but that this is a document
about which briefings have taken place
at the highest
if you're against this release but not
against the countless releases of all
the Clinton email stuff and everything
else I mentioned you are exhibiting a
double standard and I believe that this
will actually facilitate the
determination of how accurate the
information in those 35 pages is I think
the unfortunate thing is that Trump is
able to brush a lot of this stuff off
because I mean there's a lot of stuff
from this report that probably isn't
true he's probably not into urine for
example but then he's able to put that
in the same box as this idea that the
Trump transition team had or the Trump
campaign had connections with Russia
during the campaign that part is
probably likely to be true yeah I think
it's incredibly unlikely that no one on
the Trump team and no one from Russia oh
we're in touch during the campaign and
I've been saying that even before the
release of this document so I think
you're absolutely right Trump is sort of
conflating the entire thing mixing the
truth about the fact that there was a
briefing about this versus the truth of
the contents of it and then writing it
all off as fake news thanks for watching
this video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated